well on this show you know I've gone on
record quite often saying I've got a
bunch of Millennials here in the
building and we have a bunch of
Millennials that come on the show and do
their debt-free scream and so I've
become a big fan of Millennials because
the Millennials who get it get it at a
completely different level than other
generations have they get on fire for
something they're on fire for something
once they attach themselves to a cause
they will run through a brick wall and
so the sharp Millennials are the
sharpest I've seen and I don't know when
the dull Millennials are the dumbest
humans I've seen and I don't know when
the most shiftless participation trophy
living in your mother's basement group
I've ever seen and the good news about
Millennials is they're really only two
kinds fabulous and sucks and there is a
bunch of them that are fabulous and so I
don't know why I decided to take up the
cause of bragging on Millennials I think
it's because there's a group of people
my age and in the media and in some of
these stupid but magazines and stuff
that say all kinds of negative things
about them as if the entire generation
is living in their mother's basement
collecting participation trophies it's
just not true
there's a group of them that are but
there's a group of them that are
freaking rock stars too and so you know
I I guess that's why and so I'm just
kind of when I pick up one of these
articles now I don't know why I get mad
about it I don't like it
and CNN money is a become a ridiculous
publication it's just a ridiculous
publication the reason it's a ridiculous
publication is they will print anything
I don't know if they have an editor or
not that actually looks over the stuff
and goes this is bullcrap we're not
putting this in our publication because
they will print anything one article
will make a lot of sense and be very
good and the next article you would
think the guy's parents or cousins that
wrote it
I mean dumb human beings writing
articles and published in CNN money and
so I've seen everything in CNN money so
I'm you know occasionally I'll quote
something out of there positive but this
one just burned me up Millennials aren't
Oh
putting credit cards and that's a
mistake from CNN money Millennials don't
use credit cards like their parents R&R
their grandparents less than a third of
Millennials say they have a credit card
while more than half the people aged 30
to 49 owned one and nearly 70% of people
over 65 do according to a bank rate
survey financial experts chose love
where those who are those people say the
it's the fear of debt well yeah makes
sense you stupid people
that explains why young people are
shying away from credit the fear of debt
is like I don't want to go in debt
because they don't think that's good
yeah that would be well good reason not
to go in debt that's really weird
you needed a financial expert to figure
that out did you okay I'm glad you found
one to quote their vague we have no idea
who the financial expert is Millennials
have been stigmatized by that explains
Douglas Bone parth president of bonafide
wealth in New York and co-author of the
millennial money fix a book that sold a
thousand copies I don't know I've never
heard of it I'm sorry they've witnessed
firsthand the effects that mishandling
debt can bring well that would be true
many watched parents her friends slip
into debt during the 2008 financial
crisis others have been crippled by
student loans that take years to pay off
experiences like that have made
Millennials wary of spending money they
don't have oh well that's not a bad
thing I think that's called wisdom you
are the same publication making fun of
Millennials and now you're saying
they're weary of spending money they
don't have and that's a mistake
according to CNN money unbelievable and
more likely to retire on debit cards or
cash man consumer protection laws passed
after the crisis also contribute to the
generational gap the card Act of 2009
makes it harder for Millennials to
qualify for a credit card no it doesn't
unless they can prove they have enough
income to buy a bag Oh bull listen if
your breath' and they will give you a
credit card and if you're not they'll
probably still give you one those you
won't issue one in your dog's name and
your cat's name let's be real about this
while being cautious about taking on too
much debt is smart experts they're those
experts again agree using credit cards
responsibly can lead the benefits down
the road so you Millennials who are
weary of debt you're afraid of debt you
Millennials who what was the phrase
where do they go wary of spending money
you don't have
shame on you we can't have that we can't
have you Millennials who are supposed to
be shiftless and participation driven or
trophy patrícia participation trophy
driven idiots we can't have you being
responsible with your money that just
won't do oh no no we want you to build
your credit score are you thinking about
taking out a loan for a new car you'll
need a credit score yeah that would be
more debt but remember they're wary of
debt they don't like to spend money they
don't have
remember those Millennials that were
being wise like their great grandparents
yeah they had a little miniature Great
Depression experienced and crippled with
student loans as a generation and
they've learned their lesson they're not
doing it anymore
but we can't have that it's CNNMoney
that's a mistake good luck getting your
first home if you don't have a credit
score yeah because it's sending money we
don't know anything about getting a
mortgage we think you have to have a
credit score to get a mortgage that's
CNN Money we don't know about manual
underwriting so we want to be sure you
go get into debt you Millennials because
we can't have you being weary and only
spending what you make god help us no
that would [ __ ] the entire generation
oh and you're gonna miss out on rewards
you're not gonna get those rewards when
done right responsibly you can leverage
your accumulated rewards to accomplish
your goals without breaking the bank
says San Francisco's CFP George gallant
well George you're an idiot when you get
1% back on your spending and you spend a
hundred thousand dollars to get $1,000
that is not leveraging when you spend a
hundred thousand dollars to get $1,000
on your Discover card that is not
leveraging that's called stupid Oh in
fraud protection and here's the greatest
this just I mean if you're gonna print
stupid stuff at least print
stupid stuff that is the truth another
compelling reason to opt for a credit
card / debit card is because there
better safeguard against potential fraud
lie your Visa debit card has the exact
same fraud protection as your Visa
credit card your MasterCard debit card
has the exact same fraud protection
god-man if you are gonna write for
something like CNN Money at least do a
Monica of research and look at visas
website they have a zero liability
policy that extends to credit card and
debit card users if someone uses your
debit card fraudulently you are not
liable for one dime of it if you someone
uses your credit card fraudulently you
are not liable for one dime of it as the
exact same fraud protection so you
Millennials we can't have you being
responsible because then we wouldn't be
able to make fun of you so CNN Money
well that's the indirect statement here
I mean there chiding them for being wary
of spending money they don't have when
most of us would look at them and say
that's wisdom but not CNN money well not
at least this writer and it got passed
the editor if there is one this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh